ja natürlich kann man das buch empfehlen
aber es ist kein schönes buch und man
liest es nicht gern was sind das für
kategorien nicola das ist ein schönes
buch ich sage nur es setzt einem beim
lesen enorm zu das hält man für sich
beim lesen kaum haus ihre vagina ist
nichts als ein stück zerbrochenes glas
ein labyrinth aus roten streifen und
rissen eine feine eisschicht unter der
gefrorene leichen treiben
ihr charme hügel denen sie jeden tag
sorgfältig rasiert ist blau violett sie
hat es so gewollt
sie kann es ihm nicht übel nehmen es ist
hart aber es ist nicht pornographisch
und es ist nicht kitschig entsetzen wie
eine feine eisschicht unter der
gefrorene leichen treiben hat es
natürlich auch noch eine man muss sagen
poetisch metaphorische ebene
es ist vor dem vordergrund einer sehr
nüchternen sprache hat es immer diese
grundierung von melancholie es ist ein
buch was auch sehr lange noch im
nachhinein wirkt es brennt sich wirklich
ein wir sprechen heute über diesen
grosserfolg von layer slimani
französischer autoren marokkanischer
abstammung jetzt ist auf deutsch ihr
debüt erschienen das also schon viel
älter ist all das zu verlieren heißt es
eine frau die sich durch die betten
schläft die hat sex sucht also es
verheiratet hat einen sohn der relativ
klein ist ihr mannes arzt sie ist
journalistin
das ist einfach eine lehre die sie
versucht zu viel so sexy könnte
theoretisch auch sich schneiden oder sie
könnte auch polemisch sein sie könnte
trinkerin sein
ich möchte zunächst darauf hinweisen
dass es in diesem buch geht um den
zeitlosen konflikt zwischen den eigenen
wünschen und ansprüchen und auch
begehren essen und den konventionellen
vorstellungen die der gesellschaft von
glück und einem glücklichen erfüllten
leben an sich heran trägt die kritik
geht ja dahin dass man sagt das sei eine
art von auch kalkül der autorin hier das
augenmerk auf einem möglichst
skandalösen sachverhalt zu richten damit
es eben auch über shock value sich
vermarkten und natürlich noch einmal
potenziert durch die tatsache dass sie
ja aus marokkanischer herkunft ist als
leser ist man immer in der position
dass man selbst wenn man diese
schockierenden szenen liest nie das
gefühl hat das geschieht einfach nur um
mal was provozierendes zu setzen sondern
man hat immer das gefühl das illustriert
den grundkonflikt also für mich war es
glaube ich einfach auch die radikale
antwort auf eine gesellschaft die hier
geschildert wird die sehr spezifisches
die sehr stark unter
rollenzuschreibungen läuft und dann die
die radikale antwort darauf da
auszubrechen sie macht jetzt mit sex und
das ist natürlich bekannt
und vielleicht deswegen auch besonders
spannend zu lesen auch als nicht
sexsüchtiger man ohne kinder liest man
dieses buch mit gewinnen das finde ich
jetzt einen sehr schönen schlusssatz ich
habe mir mühe gegeben
[Musik]